hello everyone and welcome to the speed
chase Championship semi-final match
between Magnus Carlsen and Wesley so
this is one of the games basically the
first game of the bullet section we're
going to discuss what happened in all
the sections and we're going to discuss
what happened in the match between
Hikaru Nakamura and Maxima Shiela grab
as by now you all know we will have
another great final between Magnus
Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura so this is
the most requested game uh let's check
it out and remember this is bullet
format one minute per player and uh how
um basically a slight inaccuracy
completely turns the game around so
let's check it out Magnus has the wide
pieces he opened with Knight to F3 he
goes for the already opening and Wesley
plays Pawn to C5 which is called the the
Sicilian invitation as if White NOW goes
E4 then it's the same as if white went
to E4 then black played C5 and white
continue with Knight to F3 playing just
a standard Sicilian uh defense and
that's exactly what Magnus accept so
this is the Sicilian invitation accepted
variation but we're just is going to
call it the Cillian now the sixth wave
Pawn to see three magnets goes for the
delayed all up in variation and now
Knight to F6 putting pressure on the E4
pawn and pawn to H3 now this is uh the
way in the top three moves preventing
Bishop to G4 and while you can capture
on um E4 it's actually one of the most
common mistakes here I actually made
this mistake some 12 years ago in a in a
blitz tournament I played against I
don't know who in round one and I
thought wow a free Pawn I'm just gonna
capture it and then my opponent played
Queen day for check and I blundered at
night so you know be careful uh or that
could also be you so Knight to C6 with
Bishop to D3 now defending the pawn and
preparing Bishop to C2 so you can
advance the Deep pawn pawn to G6 and now
Bishop the C2 we have pawned the E5
Bishop to G7 is the top move here E5 um
also played quite a lot uh striking in
the center with Ponte D4 C capture C
captures and E captures on D4 and now
Knight captures on D4 is the standard
move Magnus just castles here so he's
still waiting to see if Wesley uh may
maybe make some sort of a mistake here
but Wesley just continues developing
Knight captures on D4 and now Castle so
again uh re-entering known territory
Knight to C3 and now this is a fairly
common position in the delayed all up in
where black usually goes Knight captures
on D4 or Knight captures an E4 so those
are the two moves because you don't want
to allow Knight beat an ID to B5 putting
pressure on the D6 spawn now a knife
captures on D4 pretty straightforward
you want to get the queen to D4 to maybe
try and use
um some discoveries and also Knight
captures on e4 is very popular because
now you are attacking the D4 Knight
twice so we can just trade everything
Knight captures here Knight captures and
C3 Knight captures dn9 captures on D1
now even Knight captures on F7 uh King
captures and F7 uh and The Rook captures
and the one going after the d-pawn here
and you can even give it up let's say
Bishop D6 and it's a pretty pretty
drawish end game but Wesley played Rook
to E8 it's a new move so already as of
move 11 we have a completely new game uh
what's the idea well uh he's putting
pressure on the E4 Pawn not a lot as the
pawn is being defended but his idea is
he wants to defend the D6 Pawn with Rook
to E6 once Magnus attacks it's okay
Magnus is uh of course curious he wants
to see what Wesley prepared and now Rook
to E6 which is not the best way to go
about things if you really wanna uh play
this Rook to hit move you have to play
with Rook to E7 and then if Magnus
captures the pawn then you bring the
Rook into the game let's say queen queen
characters and D6 you you attack the
Queen Once the queen moves you attack
the Knight and once the Knight moves now
you can play yeah all sorts of moves you
can play Knights the D4 you can play B6
to gain attempt on the Queen Bishop to
B7 Rook to C8 so for the price of a pawn
you will get really a lot of development
in but the Wesley played Rook did E6 and
now it's a little bit different now
Magnus plays Bishop to B3 he attacks The
Rook so of course The Rook has to move
Rook the E7 and now Magnus plays Knight
captures on D6 and now uh well of course
you can you can play Rook to B7 it's not
as potent while the Bishop is on this
diagonal as you'll see so Rook to B7 uh
Bishop to F4 Magnus defends the Knight
and just Knights to H5 trying to remove
one of the Defenders of the Knight on D6
and now look at what Magnus plays the
the position is uh already completely
winning for Magnus uh but
um uh you know it's not uh it's not all
that clear why but of course I'm sure
now you realized it is Knight captures
on F7 and now uh look at this uh Magnus
is now threatening some very nasty
Discovery so if you try trading Queens
it doesn't work because Knight captures
and the 8 comes with check and you're
always going to be down material King f8
Rook captures on D1 and after Knight
captures on F4 you will play Knight
captures and c6b captures and about any
move literally because you are of the
exchange and you have a much better
position so that's the problem with uh
you know playing playing that so what
else can you do you can't just wait for
Knight captures Queen so in the game
Rook captures an F7 was played uh okay
so he grabs the the Knight now Bishop
captures an F7 with check King captures
and now Queen to B3 with check this is a
crucial move because it allows The Rook
to enter the game uh also with Tempo and
the king is in check uh the problem is
you cannot play Bishop to E6 if you play
Bishop to E6 then Queen captures and B7
attacks the Knight attacks the king so
you have to play Knight E7 and then
Bishop G5 uh you are really not in a
great position The Rook is coming to D1
G4 is coming and it's just uh uh well a
really really bad position
I also authorized like Bishop captures
Queen captures Queen captures and A8 so
there are too many threats for you to to
handle all of them so Wesley instead
went King to f8 and now Magnus plays
Rook 8 to D1 okay Knight to D4 Wesley
again tries to trade here Queen to B4
with check King back to F7 and now
Bishop to E3 piling up on the Knight and
there's no going back here you're just
gonna lose a piece and that's it Wesley
tries one more trick Knight the C6 going
uh for for a queen trade here but now
Magnum just goes back Queen to B3 check
and he was in this position and move 22
that Wesley so resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here of
course next move you're just gonna win
the queen and if you offer a queen trade
with Bishop D6 again just Queen captures
on B7 with check and you cannot um block
this if you if you uh play 97 then you
lose the queen and if you play Queen to
E7 then of course you lose the rook and
you are just um well you're just uh
completely lost here you are you are
down two exchanges not one on so I mean
and your king is an F7 without any
defenses that's uh kind of pointless yes
you could say it's bullet so maybe
Wesley can you know do something but not
really he was already down to eight
seconds and uh in a terrible terrible
position uh so yeah uh Magnus uh so here
are the uh the standings basically of
all the time formats Magnus defeated him
in the five plus one section with six
and a half to two and a half then in
three plus one he completely demolished
him uh with a score of eight to one all
that title twos they're really really
paying off uh in the OnePlus One section
seven and a half to three and a half and
in this match it was the first time that
Wesley ever defeated Magnuson bullet uh
bringing it to a final score or a total
score of 22-7 so it's uh I mean
incredibly incredibly convincing and uh
Hikaru nakura also defeated Maxima
Cheryl Agra in the semi-finals and we
will have a Magnus Hikaru final that
everyone was expecting uh Hikaru did not
Crush uh Maxime with with such a high
margin but it was still very convincing
in the five plus one he defeated him
five to four in the three plus one three
and a half to five and a half Maxime
actually won that but in the bullet
section Hikaru
um uh completely obliterated him with a
result of eight to two so 16 and a half
to eleven and a half much much uh closer
than in the in the Magnus Wesley match
so we'll see what happened in the Hikaru
versus Magnus final uh if you remember
Hikaru defeated Magnus in the previous
speeches Championship final so this will
be an opportunity for Magnus to
retaliate I I sort of remember the
interview Magnus gave after losing that
final to Hikaru he said that he was uh
incredibly impressed by how strong
Hikaru was playing it's not that the
Magnus was playing bad or anything it's
just that Hikaru was playing so uh I
mean such incredible moves at incredible
speeds and the Magnus just couldn't I
couldn't play uh equal to it so we'll
see uh what the Magnus does here has he
improved in a year will he uh you know
uh be better this time I mean I I'm very
excited for the final as I'm sure you
guys are as well so we're going to cover
a few games from that I might even cover
the entire thing uh but uh I'm still
deciding on that uh sure that's the game
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh all
came down to this uh well I guess Rook 8
was supposed to be some sort of a
surprise but uh you know after Rook D6
Magnus just laughed at it and uh it was
downhill everything from there so yeah
once again really hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank a very happy
birthday to babsle and I would like to
thank Raymond young and soul heartstein
uh Paul Miller and Kenneth Frazier for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day